(Guitar music)
I was just thinking
that I have been missing you way too long
There's something inside this weary head
that wants us to love just instead
But I was just thinking,
merely thinking
I've got loads of pictures,
I've got the one of you
in that dancing dress
But man I feel silly in that dim light
Just after doing you
by the sight of my Kodak delights,
I am sinking,
merely sinking
I think about long distance rates
instead of kissing you babe
I'm a singer without a song
If I wait for you longer
my affection is stronger
and I ... I was just thinking,
merely thinking
that this boat is sinking
I'm tired of postcards,
especially the ones
with cute dogs and cupids
I'm tired of calling you and missing you
and dreaming I slept with you
Don't get me wrong
I still desperately love you
inside this weary head
I just want us to love just instead
But I was just thinking and thinking,
merely thinking
I think about long distance rates
instead of kissing you babe
and time is running me still
If I wait for you longer
my affection is stronger
I ... I was just thinking
that I'm tired of calling you once a week
thinking of long distance rates
instead of kissing you
So baby I'm sinking,
merely sinking
(Guitar music ends)
(Applause)
Thank you.
Singing is sharing.
When you sing, you have to know
what you're talking about intimately,
and you have to be willing
to share this insight
and give away a piece of yourself.
I look for this intention
to share in everything,
and I ask: what are the intentions
behind this architecture or this product
or this restaurant or this meal?
And if your intentions
are to impress people
or to get the big applause at the end,
then you are taking, not giving.
And this is a song that's about --
it's the kind of song that everyone
has their version of.
This song is called "Home,"
and it's sort of a "This is where
I'm from, nice to meet you all,"
kind of song.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
(Piano music)
Home is the sound of birds
early in the morning
Home is a song I've always remembered
Home is the memory
of my first day in school
Home is the books that I carry around
Home is an alley in a faraway town
Home is the places I’ve been
and where I’d like to go
Home
I'm always gonna feel at home
No matter where I may roam
I'm always gonna find my way back home
No matter how far I’m gone
I’m always gonna feel this longing
No matter where I might stay
Home is a feather twirling in the air
Home is flowers in a windowsill
Home is all the things she said to me
Home is a photo I never threw away
Home is the smile on my face when I die
Home is the taste of an apple pie
I met a woman, she always lived
in the same place
And she said home is where
you’re born and raised
And I met a man, he sat
looking out to the sea
And he said home is where you want to be
I met a girl in some downtown bar
And she said I'll have
whatever he's having
And I asked her how come
we never met before?
And she said all my life I’ve been trying
to get a place of my own
I’m always gonna feel at home
No matter where I may roam
Always gonna find my way back home
No matter how far I’m gone
I'm always gonna feel this longing
No matter where I might stay
(Piano music)
(Piano music ends)
(Applause)